hey everyone
welcome to simply learns youtube channel
today in this video
we'll discuss a very interesting and a
very important topic that is a mean
squared error
where it is used and why do we actually
need this mean squared function
when there are already so many methods
to evaluate the model
so watch this video till the end
and if this is your first visit to our
channel please click on the subscribe
button so that you do not miss any
update
let's start by defining what is mean
squared error
mean squared error measures the amount
of error in a statistical model
it calculates the average squared
difference between the observed and
predicted values
in regression line the mean squared
error represents the average squared
residual
as you can see in the graph as the data
points fall closer to the regression
line the model has a less error
decreasing the mean squared error
a model with less error produces more
precise predictions
now let's jump to our excel workbook and
discuss it with an example
here we have a small table with the
actual and predicted values
we'll start by finding the error
between the actual and predicted value
which will be the difference between the
actual minus predicted values so here 10
minus 7 will become 3
16 minus 14 will become 2
13 minus 17 will become
minus 4
19 minus 20 becomes minus 1
and 7 minus 4 becomes 3.
now just calculate the total of the
errors
while calculating the total we'll treat
this negative value as a positive value
so here the total of the errors will
become 3 plus 2 5 plus 4 9 1 10 and 13.
then we'll calculate the square of the
errors
so here 3 square will become 9
2 square will become 4 4 square will
become 16
1 square will become 1 and 3 square
again is 9
and
we'll do the total of the square errors
so this will become 9 plus 4 13 13 plus
1
14
14
plus 16 30 and 39
to find the mse
that is the mean squared error we'll
divide the total of the square error
values with the total number of records
so here mse
will be equal to
39 divided by and we have total number
of records that is 5
which will be 7.8
let's name this
as model a
now for the comparison purpose we'll
create another model that is model b
we'll have
all the columns here
and we'll keep the actual values here
same
we'll just change the predicted values
so let's take some random values um
we'll keep this as 13 we'll take this as
20
i'll take this as 12 18 and 3
now to calculate the error we'll
subtract the predicted values from the
actual values so 10 minus 13 will become
minus 3 16 minus 20 will become minus 4
this will become 1
this will be 1 and this will be
4.
now to calculate the square error we'll
just square the error values
so this will be 9 this will be 16
this will be 1 this will be one and this
will be 16.
the total of all the square values will
come out to be 43
now to calculate the mse again we'll
divide the
total square values with the total
number of records so here this will be
equal to 43
divided by 5
which will come out to be 8.6
if you observe here the total of the
errors in both model a and model b is
same that is 13.
so which model to prefer
since the mean squared error of model a
is lesser than model b
we prefer model a
because
we are okay with a model that has small
small errors but in model b
there are some significantly large
errors suppose in this case 16 minus 20
that is minus 4 minus 3 and this here 4.
so we do not want a model where the
errors large errors specifically are
more frequent
we can have a model with the small
errors that will be okay
so we'll prefer model a over model b
this brings us to the end of this video
and i hope you liked the video
if yes
please like the video
and don't forget to subscribe our
channel
see you in our next video until then
happy learning
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here